[Musique]
ambiance studieuse dans cette salle de
répétition à voisins le bretonneux pour
les 32 musiciens amateurs du foulbazar
small band un groupe né en 2002 qui
comptait au départ seulement quelques
saxophoniste au fil du temps des
trompettes des clarinettes ou encore des
flûtes sont venus augmenter les rangs de
leurs qu'istres et s'appelle foulbazar
small bang c'était à la base pour faire
opposition au big band qui est donc un
orchestre à on va dire de petite
quinzaine de musiciens normalement et
typique jazz est bon là on explose
effectivement là le nombre du big band
depuis près de 20 ans le groupe
participe à la vie culturelle de
voisins-le-bretonneux et donnera le 25
janvier son concert annuel à la salle de
la tour thématique cette année le voyage
aérien
au total une quinzaine de morceaux de
jazz de rock et de funk sont prévues
pour deux heures de représentation
scanner la difficulté c'est vraiment le
rythme on a des morceaux un petit peu
plus compliqué que l'année d'avant
encore fabienne un peu de challenge est
là dessus et voilà c'est bien se placer
bien être dans le rythme des tempos un
petit peu différent de d'habitude malgré
les difficultés à exécuter certains
morceaux sans fausse note les adhérents
prennent plaisir à se retrouver chaque
semaine pour les répétitions générales
fait de retrouver une bonne bande de
copains parce que mme annoncé et c'est
devenu voilà tous des amis des copains
et puis la musique forcément le style de
musique
le choix des morceaux voilà
ya pas mal de facteurs qui fait que je
m'accroche et à quelques jours du jour j
les moins stressés semblent être les
enfants
j'ai déjà fait beaucoup de concerts
devant bas à peu près 500 personnes donc
je suis un peu habitué je stresse pas
trop j'ai déjà fait plein de conseils
n'ont jamais eu trop le trac un peu
l'habitude
[Musique]